the moment has arrived the waiting is
over
no composer should be asked to remain
composed for so long the nominees for
best song are against all odds take a
look at me now from against all odds
music and lyrics by Phil Collins
from Whitley
music and lyric by Kenny Loggins and
Dean pitchman
Ghostbusters from Ghostbusters music and
lyric by Ray Parker jr.
I just called to say I love you from a
woman in red music and lyric by Stevie
Wonder
let's hear it for the boy from Footloose
music and lyric by Tom Snow and Dean
pitch for Stevie Wonder
[Applause]
[Music]
I cannot I cannot believe it I really
cannot believe it
I I must share this with you take just a
second I think but I'm all through
Europe I had dreams and I would always
wake up and I was in a ward show and the
anomalies are coming up and they say
this song of this song and the winner is
I would wake up but I never thought that
this would happen
I never thought this would happen I
would like to accept this board award
the name of Nelson Mandela I'd like to
think first of all misty on Warwick for
Longley this opportunity like a like to
thank Gene Wilder for thinking I might
be able to do some songs for your film
thank Ron pictures and thank Motown
Records and my family and my crew from
my heart
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]